laughter I finished ghost wars I felt
that I had left Saudi Arabia on the
table as a subject to some extent and I
wanted to go back to it I had worked on
bin Laden over a long period of time as
a reporter 10 or 15 years and I had
worked on him in the context of the
Afghan Wars and in the context of
International Islamic radicalism but I
felt that there was still another story
to work on not just in reference to him
but in reference to Saudi Arabia about
the experience of modernization in the
kingdom after the oil shocks in the 70s
and to try to understand both Osama to
reinterpret Osama but also even without
reference to him to write about the
diversity of experiences and identities
and the fluidity of identity that many
Saudis of his generation wrestled with
in the in the period after the 70s I've
been coming and going from Saudi Arabia
since 1990 and it's a very difficult
place to write about in an authentic
specific way it's a difficult place to
work as a journalist hard to research
them not very many points of entry and
you sort of have this intuition that
there is something complicated and
interesting and more modern and more
more accessible to an American audience
than the cliched political cartoon of
the long chin shake pouring gasoline
into an American car would offer and so
I was really looking for a story to
write about Saudi Arabia as well as
about bin Laden
well I think all of these sort of binary
models for thinking about this conflict
us versus them as Christianity versus
Islam the West versus the East the North
versus the South all of them while
offering valid frameworks for debate and
forethought none of them is useful in
the real lives that that Saudis or other
Arabs experience because the world is
just too fluid and too flat and
especially in the Gulf after the oil
boom and so much change was happening so
fast in so many ways that to draw lines
on a map and say some people lived on
one side of the line and other people
living on the other side of the line
it's just it's falsifying it's confusing
it actually takes you away from the
subject and so to get to the sort of
myths I mean what interested me about
bin Laden and what I thought I would
find in trying to place him in his in
his family's story and what I also
thought I would find just in the family
without reference to him is a story
about modernization and the experience
of modernization in the specific lives
of golf Saudis in the 1970s forward and
why would we be interested in the
particular complexities of modernization
in Saudi Arabia well because 19 of them
turned up on these airplanes in New York
and Washington and so trying to just
create another way to contextualize
those faces and that and that mystery
was was a lot of the of the interest in
the project
was in many ways a familiar type in that
he created a great fortune by force of
will and charisma and ambition and in
doing that he built up a whole sort of
family and and and business in his own
image what was interesting about him was
not the kind of outline of immigrant
comes to Saudi Arabia is illiterate has
talent creates fortune which is a
narrative that we've seen in lots of
cultures and settings what was
interesting was the thing he built in
his own image and it was a family and an
idea about success that was rooted in a
number of things that surface in Osama
bin Laden's later Talent one was his
ability in the in the pre-modern
environment of early Saudi Arabia to
create a very modern company I mean he
had he was an early pioneer in what we
now call globalization he had engineers
and and architects from Italy he had
suppliers on Broadway in New York in the
1950s he had workers from Sudan and
Nigeria he had pilots from Afghanistan
and Pakistan he built a multinational
multi-ethnic multi-linguistic
construction company and broader
enterprise in a place where that just
didn't really exist very in very many
ways and and it was his style of
leadership his ability to attract and
organize Global Diversity around an
enterprise that inspired his sons I
think mostly inspired his sons to do
similar things in business and inspired
one son to do similar things in jihad
but it was this model of modernity and
globalization and organization one and
two this streak of charismatic genius in
the family that is really located in the
father
he had a talent a gift and intuition
about how to organize people and how to
create something out of nothing and he
also had a way of living that was very
active and and just absolutely
impervious to borders or to convention
he was a traveler he was a man who who
always saw himself as part of a wider
world not just one city one visit he was
very difficult to contain and in his
sons this streak of charismatic genius
is visible in the secular lives of some
of his business oriented sons who were
equally unusual in their talents and
their way of living an adventurous and
full of risk and ambition and then in a
distorted sort of fragmented way it
takes you to Osama and it's sort of it
sets his achievements and and the his
sort of talent in a in a line and in a
context that I found very interesting I
didn't expect that but it was what I
discovered it was it had to do with
Osama's money I mean up until nine
eleven both President Clinton and
President Bush and their cabinets and
everybody else who was cleared to read
intelligence reporting about the problem
of al-qaeda that everyone was saying was
around was given reporting from the
intelligence community saying that Osama
had a personal fortune of three hundred
million dollars and the relevance of
this was that he was self-funding all of
this terrorist activity so that so that
basically whatever strategy you might
use against him just had to recognize
he's gotta be was like going up against
the Ford Foundation he had a huge
endowment and he was just going to be
hard to deal with in that respect well
that turned out to be completely wrong
in fact his inheritance was you know
maybe 20 million dollars over 20 years
25 million over 20 years and the whole
time that presidents and cabinets were
receiving this information it turned out
as I found when I was researching the
book and had this gun one of these sort
of great investigative reporter Eureka
moments
the basement of the los angeles county
superior court in an open court file
involving the divorce of one of us amoz
brothers the ex-wife of that brother
suspecting that he was not telling her
the truth about his income hired a
forensic accountant to go to Saudi
Arabia and audit the whole bin Laden
family money system and this forensic
accountant came back and filed a report
that's was sitting there in an open file
saying okay here's exactly how much
money the brothers get here's what
percentage of the company they own you
know they only get this much money a
year their total inheritances maybe
10-20 me I mean the amount of money that
he had inherited was sitting in an open
court file from 1993 until the present
and no one had gone to look at it so I
mean I'm like a mildly trained reporter
who knows that you go do civil lawsuits
when you're looking at something
complicated and for all those years
nobody as a taxpayer I just thought it
was really frustrating nobody from the
FBI nobody from the CIA just like did
the thing you would do like a look at
all the civil cases in the u.s.
involving bin Laden's and look at the
files and see what you learn
there is always a little bit of mystery
about why someone makes the kinds of
commitments and and choices that someone
like him makes but it's more or less
transparent and in the end he's a fairly
stubborn and not a very complicated
personality in some respects he sort of
starts on a path and what's remarkable
about him is his fortitude in his and
his stubbornness in staying on a path
even as all kinds of risks and costs
accumulate but the but the part that
doesn't really the most enduring mystery
to me still even though I feel like I
was you know I spent a long time trying
to unpack it and tried to bring as much
as I could forward in the book there is
there are layers still about Osama's
relationship with the Saudi
establishment and with his family that I
think if fully known would turn out to
be even more complicated and even more
ambiguous than the I hope somewhat
complicated habitué a sport road I've
sketched with the information available
the point is in summary that we think of
Osama as a radical and our interest in
him is as a radical oh how did he become
radicalized when did he turn away from
the but that but the context from a
Saudi perspective is that he was to a
much greater extent than our narrative
would allow he was an orthodox figure he
was an entirely authorized figure he was
somebody that people were proud of he
was he was legitimate he was in fact
more than legitimate he was a source of
a reputation for the family with the
government he was an instrument of Saudi
foreign policy now he wasn't he wasn't
opposed to it he was a he was a he was
an example of what a proud family like
the bin Laden's in the context of Saudi
Arabia could produce on in the religious
side of the family and so something
about that stature that he had the
orthodoxy that he represented I think is
very Saudi and very elusive
and I felt like I got you know maybe a
quarter of the way toward what a
unencumbered researcher with access to
everything maybe even if maybe even only
ten percent of the way there if Osama
and everyone else would really talk
honestly about how this inside-outside
journey to and from Saudi Arabia
happened that would be a really
interesting story